this is a conflict being played out in
social media every day but
disinformation is also a weapon of War
Sky News we use different tools and
techniques to verify information before
we use it in our journalism over the
last few months as we've covered the
developments in the war in Ukraine
you'll have seen a lot of this our
presenters and Military experts
exploring regions being fought for
looking at Maps but where the Sky News
get the information to make these Maps
here are the institutes for the study of
War publish daily reports to their
website of the latest movements which we
then use to show you what's going on
they use geolocation and on the ground
reporting to verify pictures and video
to get an idea of the movements of
troops in any given area we then turn
that into our maps that you see
to take the example of her song So this
video was released by Ukrainian units
claiming to show them raising a
Ukrainian flag over Mira lubivka as you
can see it's filmed inside a stairwell
so not much to go on from these images
alone but pay attention to the blue
structure on the roof that's important
another video posted online a few days
earlier shows Ukrainian troops
inspecting a building there's a kind of
pans we can see the same blue structure
to the one in the images they shared we
can now use this video which has more
detail to try and locate the building
and potentially confirm its shot where
we've been told it is scanning satellite
imagery of the area we're looking for a
large building maybe a school or a
hospital and come across this building
its shape and style completely matches
that of the one in the videos from
before and we can be doubly sure here
because lots of people in the open
source Community look at verifying
videos and someone has found the website
for a school in Mira lubivka the picture
of the school matches perfectly
with the video
as well as taking ground military
experts say Ukrainian soldiers are also
good at fighting the information War
recently they've been posting content
from landmarks that is fairly easy to
verify the quicker things are verified
the quicker they reach the public domain
and the results increased Morale on the
ground like here the soldiers enter the
strategically important town of liman in
the Donetsk region at the beginning of
the month they published this video and
here it is
a government building geolocating
footage from the conflict can sometimes
be complex but we can see here they want
to get this out there but sometimes it
is more complicated we'll leave you with
this a soldier filming a selfie video
claiming to be from Turney in Donetsk as
we can see some buildings behind him
they give us a clue but remember it's a
selfie video which means that what we're
actually seeing is a mirror view of the
reality if we look at Google Maps we can
see the buildings the opposite way
around and even work out whether a man
was standing when he filmed it so you've
seen here how our team are verifying
claims by Ukraine and will continue to
use these sort of techniques over the
coming weeks